we also understand the need to keep the
economy going to keep providing for our
families and quite frankly we know how
to do that best we need that one life
back we want to be able to ward there's
a lot of people that are hurting not
just people getting sick from this virus
but people that are their entire
livelihoods are being upended by this
many of those protestors saying in the
virus not the economy let's bring in Dan
bond Geno Fox News contributor former
Secret Service agent former NYPD officer
author Andy has a podcast good morning -
Dan good to see you it's been a while
just see you - I know we've missed you
so we wanted to bring you in because
some of these protests are gonna take
place in your state down in Florida
there are ten different states where
these protests will take place today
alone what do you make of that and what
site do you see both sides were you or
are you leaning in one direction
well easy rare leaders have been a topic
I've been so passionate to get on the
air and discuss than this of course I
see both sides I have a family and I
have two children myself I have a
mother-in-law and two parents that are
still alive that obviously I care deeply
about my mother herself is in an
extremely high-risk category if she
would have contract this it could could
be deadly but a Z I have to feed my kids
- so does everybody around here you know
and I watched that clip before the break
of Nancy Pelosi seemingly confused about
what protesters we're doing well let me
enlighten you Nancy because you seem to
be living in an insulated $25,000
freezer ice cream bubble and you don't
get it
here it is plain and simple people have
to feed their families these are smart
Americans who are intelligent they
understand there's a risk they live with
risk every day if you need to understand
that Nancy go talk to a construction
worker on a construction site down the
block that is living with multi-million
dollar equipment that could kill him in
a minute
if you tell him or her on that site
you're gonna need to wear a mask there
are precautions we may have to wear some
kind of hand protection wash our hands
off and we may have to distance but
you'll be able to go to work and feed
your kids I promise you the
entrepreneurial brave American citizens
will figure it the hell out get out of
your bubble people have to feed their
that is what's going on right now and
then I'll talk to you afterwards but
just to give people an idea of what they
might have missed his Nancy Pelosi is
halting delivery in trying to explain
what the protestors are up to can you
understand why they're doing that no not
really because what we have to do is is
is shelter in place that is really the
answer
testing tracing treatment shelter in
place and I do think that it's
unfortunate but you know people will do
what they do but the fact is we're all
impatient we all want out but what
they're doing is really unfortunate but
what they're in doing is not unfortunate
they're doing is exercising their rights
they could have been socially distant
protesting I get that and there are
places that are hot spots but then if
you do put in sprinklers for a living in
ground sprinklers and you say you can
only do it certain times you've got to
wear a certain mask let them do it but
let they if somebody wants to build a
house on the outside distant from each
other by design let them do it there's
no need to be excessively punitive about
this is that your point yes and Brian
whereas in the beginning where we had a
lockdown of our economy nationwide
basically America the American people
are bright they understood there was a
lot of uncertainty in the beginning they
are not the contagiousness level of this
disease the lethality of it how exactly
it's spread whether you know was it
fomites droplets in the beginning
because we were getting a lot of
misinformation everybody I think
understood in the effort to save you
know potentially at that point what they
thought were millions of lives the
president made it the right decision but
now Brian we have our grasp around the
data you don't need to be an
epidemiologist to read simple figures
about this we have a better grasp of how
it's we don't know everything and
hopefully we'll figure more out but we
have a good grasp at it's only
reasonable then to allow Americans to
take the data you've given them and to
say here are the
pria measures for you to go back to work
and be able to feed your kids and one
more thing Brian Nancy Pelosi can't
figure out we're doing these people
Gretchen Whitmer and others it's not
just Democrats either it's just some
Republican governors too they work for
us that's not a slogan that's not some
campaign talking if I'm not running for
office these people work for us get the
hell out of our way you're supposed to
make our lives easier not more difficult
everyday understanding there's a safety
issue we get it they work for us stop
talking like I just like it like it says
like romper room we're not children
we're adults we've lived much harder
lives and these people who are governing
us a joke the way they talk to people I
don't understand what they're doing well
figure it the hell out that's your darn
job to understand what we're doing well
you know then I think what we're
learning is that a one-size-fits-all
approach does not work all across the
country because where you're sitting in
Stuart Florida it's a much different
environment than about a hundred miles
south in Miami which has been a hot spot
and when you look at the numbers this
particular illness impacts the people
over 65 in a gigantic way and going
forward we now know that until there is
a vaccine those people have got to be
insulated but had we heard from China
earlier maybe we would have had a better
handle on this we had Jay Johnson on
with us a little while ago about 40
minutes ago and he said the numbers out
of China in the beginning simply did not
add up listen in a country four times
the size of ours I simply don't believe
they've been topped out at 83,000 cases
I look at these numbers daily and China
has been at 81 82 83 thousand four weeks
in a country of 1.4 billion people so I
simply don't believe that number China
has to be dealt with one way or another
but I think we've got to stay focused on
the the lethal public health crisis
right here at home right so Dan how do
you deal with China one way or the other
well well Steve there's a difference in
law and elsewhere between you know miss
fees
- now fees it's right misfeasance of us
someone falls on the sidewalk in front
of you you know you don't help them up
that's misfeasance right but if someone
falls on the sidewalk in front of you
and you punch them in the face as they
go to get up that's malfeasance okay
that's what China did here I think every
country in the world would have
understood if China had just wasn't what
didn't have a good grasp of the
situation themselves and put out some
information that later turned out to be
inaccurate it happens all the time
especially in a crisis that's clearly
not what happened here
China didn't put out a mistake China put
out deliberate misinformation to people
that confused them and potentially led
to hundreds of thousands of unnecessary
lives being lost if they just would have
put out the information appropriately
from the start and making it worse Steve
they piled on in the end engaged in an
extensive identity politics based
understanding our soft spot the United
States identity politics based
propaganda effort using people in our
media to cover up any potential
criticism of China as xenophobic which
was totally nonsense the truth-tellers
were the ones silenced by some not all
but some in the media which was really
gross okay Dan thank you so much for
being with us great to be back it's
really good to see you it's always good
to see you too